pour l'instant comment ça va alors on
bonne année bonne année soit pour sa
nouvelle année celui-ci alors j'ai pas
fait grand chose un pic à alors je vous
direz vous le plâtre oui ça me va me va
très bien depuis qu'il sait péter lamont
allé d'un coup plus beau cadeau à tous
les potes vous pas que la deuxième avant
les vacances
il a fait son type mpila fait son record
d'audience sur une jambe oui c'est vrai
mais fou c'est fou hein et d'aïn en vrai
un texto de textes qu'à sa deuxième
passe c'est vrai mais c'est vrai parce
qu'on fait avec plaisir en tout cas si
je peux rendre service
alors content de vous retrouver ma mère
si mon chéri que vous avez fait pendant
ces vacances jeudi à feu pas grand chose
en fait y'a maghrébine et amaigri a
maigri et c'est la chaise encore comme
j'aime mais en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'agis comme j'aime ça marche que si oui
alors est donc ouais alors non j'ai rien
faire ça va très bien là ce que
généralement alors je vous dis 80% des
divorces se font avec une personne qui a
la jambe cassée un réseau la sajo comme
ça je connais par coeur le boulot ni je
connaisse tout va bien au delà bien
valérie bénaïm laquelle tigresse ceci
alors elle est partie elle est partie en
italie
non je le sais beinheim alafé florence
et elle mais je lui au téléphone parce
que c'est une des seules duo téléphone
ici dans l'équipe parce qu'on est très
très connectée beinheim et moins faim
j'ai eu également mathieu pour une 207
plombier ouais merci j'ai eu j'ai eu qui
maxime je suis tout le monde j'ai chez
moi la raconte pas la cua ne compte pas
alors si vous avez vu tout le monde vous
avez oui c'est vrai du tout le monde
mais benhaim j'ai eu un peu plus que les
autres
elle m'a raconté ses vacances et super
benhaim elle a fait un jour un musée oui
vous avez retenu ma formule café un jour
amusé avec son amoureux y avait ces mets
donc votre amoureux pas exact pas de
touche oui toujours le même depuis que
vous avez démarré ppp tout à fait c'est
comme avec moins de temps suisse a fait
plus de six ans vous allez en mariage à
florence je sens qu'il va plus entre
deux bus est à mon avis et si on se
mariait depuis que vous avez la
quotidienne plus de l'oseille mariage
corp apparemment pas à moi qu'il va pas
moins à proposer ou non nous sommes très
amoureux tous les naïves mais à moi ya
pas eu un petit gobain mais non pas du
tout une petite bague nom des doigts à
monter doit on était noire monte douane
on monte monte doigt de pied gagnants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va me changer ça te permet des noms
mais nous sommes très amoureux très
heureux qu'il pense
alors je pose la question du futur
twitter c'est monde est content de
retrouver qui pense qu'il ya eu un bail
entre benhaim et son mec est ce qu'il
est et qu'il lui a demandé qui l'attend
menace est nul et je demande us a
annoncé ce qui s'est passé puisque je
vous raconte tout j'ai demandé son
départ il nous savons tout de suite
demandé ce que tu aimes les crêpes et
j'ai vu son regard c'est vous le regard
de benhaim etc vous savez le regard
vitreux le regarde quand tu reçois ta
feuille d'impôt celi besnaïnou cache
quelque chose
pas du tout c'est en arabe je suis béni
[Rires]
mellal
mais la ive attention ça peut être
l'objet d'une première enquête de babar
non il a cédé des vacances formida alors
vous étiez avec votre mari y met et
votre fine si c'est donc 53 ans comment
travailler mais voilà c'était à
l'occasion de ce rock 2 voilà de passer
du meeddm tançant ébahis moments
ensemble et lime non la vitre je vais
venir sur vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention minimes non mais vous êtes mon
frère je sais quelle famille à ses
gaffes parce que même avec une jambe
4 je te fais gaffe bonjour michel
mercier et d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je
voulais que ça car tout ici et voilà
votre bonne résolution pour wasquehal
pour 2019 booster quoi bon j'arrête la
moto arrêter les divorces aussi la moto
avant dans ses réserves
franchement je ne veux plus voir sur une
moto non mais là je vois sur une moto
même manège je te pète le feu
[Rires]
ça va non mais je stocke togo de la
gueule en a vraiment mérité
c'était comme mon frère tôt si j'arrête
la moto l'accord très mauvais name is it
est un mariage non mais justement voir
plus ma famille faire des dîners entre
amis à la démission il ya plein de gens
qui voudraient faire la quotidienne non
non voilà vous narre mais la bonne
raison que vous moi maigrir non harry
adama donc j'ai pris une résolution je
me suis pris en photo le 1er janvier et
je j'accepterais de passer la photo qui
est vraiment dégueulasse ans séparent
pas inventé mais c'est dégueulasse
donc le 1er juin je veux perdre 15 kilos
c'est facile à 96 c'est possible c'est à
rien faut lui péter la jambe
[Rires]
c'est rien c'est une baleine est donc
bon on va suivre ça et je serai motivé
parce que la photo franchement elle est
on va vous rose et toutes les semaines
et ce qu'on peut la voir est ce qu'on
peut avoir une balance s'il vous plaît
et je parle pas de matthieu delormeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on va se poser on vous rappellera qu'en
semaine pour voir l'évolution d'accord
qu'est ce qui se passe mais toutes les
7e et que vous allez faire des
commentaires
pas les manquer alors ça moi aussi mais
mon cabinet c'est un opus et quand a été
en italie elle me répondait jamais ça me
rend des fois je te réveilles le tout
encore en train de manger léger pas quoi
la voiture a bien répondu s'il m'avait
appelé 1
alors je viens juste avec votre bbox ne
capte pas
[Applaudissements]
bon alors lui alors je vais vous dire
oui il ya eu 2018 et 2010 il se prend
pour un beau gosse l'émission de magic a
marché j'ai eu au téléphone
oui je l'appelle à 9h02 pour les
audiences sex-shop
c'est vrai qu'on est premier sur les 15
34 mais dis-moi sérieusement qu'est ce
que tu penses de mon score sur la chaîne
modique c'est exceptionnel à moi de les
féliciter parce que j'adore ta fais tu
sais que je t'aime moi mon maxi c'est
plutôt prénom
[Rires]
oh ça va
ayrault ça va au récent de huit étages
là alors on va remercier après la guerre
alors lui même j'ai eu à la pelle
spontanée d'autre part bien sûr c'est
très bien même pendant les vacances vous
êtes fidèles proche de votre public
à votre tour spectateurs un peu de soi
même et des comptes ce sera votre
première intervention 2009
on a des photos lui parce qu'il est
parti en guadeloupe
l'équipe française arrive à losail un
sapin et des mandragores au mollet il
est beau il est beau et c'est là entre
la sela entre la dalle alors que les
bactéries voudront nous faut donc bien
que mal et n'être qu'à quelques mois
dans mad men est parce que qui prend la
photo là un itinérant d'après des
médecins ce qui a affecté en guadeloupe
avec 2,3 à 12h03 qui ne servent à
faleyras es où il n'existe plus tout ça
est le job à écouter un peu de personnes
après je me demandais si je vous
demandais de me laisser faire
allez vous allez me laisser faire ne
vous occupez pas tu as une affaire entre
lui et moi mais ma soeur ma question est
simple avec qui est reparti en
guadeloupe avec une bande de potes a
alors on trois personnes oui juste moi
ils étaient quatre oui on peut avoir les
noms donc ouais nouveau boulot qu'ils
occupaient il a dû mcqueen jurer de rien
du tout c'est un problème de
compréhension
c'est un petit problème ne comprend
souris mais du jus dance études et soit
ça n'est rien
je répète ma question peut-on savoir
avec qui vous êtes parti line pris nos
noms
il va nous faire une la guerre s'il
arrive à nous faire une naga
voilà là ils sont en quête d'anonymat
qu'est-ce que vous on sait très bien que
tu es pas parti avec ryan gosling
annoncé que par alan mousseline des ryan
son parti alors non juste après n'ont
voulu rejoindre bernard
[Rires]
sinon tu as rejoint christine kelly a
même fait ses voeux à la radio sa
certitude il est attendu des radios web
alors tout ça il faut aussi avoir le
coup de la guadeloupe ah ouais ouais
ouais ya quelques années je veux dire
toi que tu as vu toi le célibat lui il
va tomber dans mon pied alors je n'ai
pas ça t il digne fars
[Rires]
ça glisse hashtag chatouiller les nus
favoriser l'expression vous je sais
alors vous avez dû faire le pigeon pour
fatou je vais pas les morales qu'il a
fait beau et vacances qu'on met la
dépense et non mais j'ai changé parce
que j'ai offert des habits rien à l'aise
j'ai passé les jours suivants a tout
changé
non mais dans toutes les boutiques donc
ça t'a fait toutes les vacances question
de chemise
quand je vois comme ça ça va là on a
rouvert le tex mex mais quoi alors oui
alors on a quoi alors on a deux s'agite
alors c'est tout il a fait quoi pour le
jour de l'an
alors là on est sorti chez des amis ah
ouais ouais ces photos on est parti en
1ère royal parce que j'ai absolument
voulu qu'on prenne le rer
[Rires]
vous pensez que vous allez finir 2010
avec fatou au la question rien donné non
on est au franchement au nirvana
non c'est pas ici d une période mais
away manger à sa dure pas longtemps mais
là je suis confiant je comprends vous
très vite ou c'est quoi votre résolution
pour 2009 puisque arrêter d'être gentil
j'ai été trop gentil
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes resté au maire noël
bonne chance contrairement à ben oui
[Rires]
mais c'est comme ça maintenant un effet
rock alors remettez ça d'abord on met en
scène ben ouais il n'y avait pas
d'enfants les nouvelles chattant une
belle charge alors moi je sais ce que
j'ai fait pour la vie tu nous appelles
doux à huy mathieu 6,8 liberté une telle
vendredi ce compact mac au téléphone
dans la tronche alors preuve le premier
de l'an j'ai chatouiller du nénuphar on
va dire mais mais sa tournée du nez
mutin alors c'est pas pareil puisque
vous c'était peut-être pas d'une
histoire c'est pas plutôt cactus
non je connais je suis si les prochaines
sur les plaines de casser sa pipe je me
suis pas rendu compte à gaza qui
chatouille
j'ai dit à mes amis sur place pour nous
on a fait un truc assez drôle on va
commencer à 23h30 à faire l'amour à
finir à 00h30
j'aurais fait l'amour avec vous pendant
deux ans avec un effort non alors mes
résolutions mais résolution rapide ma
révolution sauvez l'amour cette année
lors on peut plus mon nom c'est vrai
cinq ans que ça dure non non là c'est
vraiment vraiment on arrête les bêtises
trouver l'amour est d'ailleurs à ce
propos j'ai jamais trouvé aussi beau que
cette année ça c'est vrai et j'ai envie
de parler avec le coeur parce que vous
l'avez fait tout à lui préféré que je
parlais avec le choeur quelque chose
jusqu'à maintenant c'était un petit peu
pour rire là cette année vraiment je
pourrais vraiment week-end
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment l'impression que tous
venaient en roulis well as ahmed porte
ouverte à beaucoup de conneries que j'ai
fini il paraît que je voulais courir et
de manger le professeur grave mais tout
allait s'arrêter à la casse est
l'ambiance au tailleur cammas deux
minutes c'était s'il n'a pas l'amour
dans des coupes pas les autres ma belle
mère si c'était vous dire d'être comme
tout le monde
tant que je suis libre je ne vous
intéresse pas le jour où je serai plus
libre bah vous serez stérile va tenter
des trucs que vous verrez votre télé
c'est comme les taxis ça on veut
toujours le taxon ya des gens dedans
merci moi comme ça les choses à vous
tous merci pour la comparaison d'un taxi
à écouter bachelot n'est pourtant vous
êtes souvent tarifs c'est parce sa patte
bonsoir alors vous bonnes résolutions
c'est peut-être rêvé de chanter alors
vous vous êtes laissé sûr si vous aviez
gagné astarac la nation est un jeu fait
un procès c'est quoi votre bonne
résolution mois un marié non way aussi
croyais je suis rocher zeitoun
organiseur de mariage crois que c'est
les trekkers est uni 6 mois à 10 ans est
passé à la personne déjà sauvé la
personne banon mais je suis vous êtes
avec un corse a beau répéter s'ébroue
pas non
j'aurai le jeu crasher sur matthieu
delormeau a dit la vérité
alors ne monte pas il savait ce qu'elle
faisait et musc est arrivé capucine ana
[Musique]
il adore ça pis si elle a menti un jour
son jeune âge ou mensonge toujours
attention attention alors des plats
mérité on est sur un petit truc en plus
ouais accord soit les mecs et vous et
12h et kaduna avant même que vous ayez
gallas et le mec si c'est déjà une
application simple la galoche arrivera
dans ce cas c est vous avez des champs
encore ce n'est déjà pas que théo savez
quand vous êtes le t2 toblerone un
[Rires]
citoyen directement les étoiles j'ai
déjà en corse
sachez le pari s'est fait très bien
placé là bas calmez-vous donc hors des
101 et on mange du saucisson et on ferme
sa dissidence aussi son corps sa voix
mais j'adore le regarder
merci d'être là mon poto chéri on a
quand même fait une heure d'émission à
dire que des conneries mais ça va
continuer windsor a continué
ça va très bien pour la récré et moi ma
résolution pour 2019 c'est d'être en
bonne santé et de gagner un petit peu
plus d'argent alors deuxième alors jouer
au foot et refaire du sport alors au
faîte plutôt d'histoire
j'ai vu dans l'est j'ai lu dans le haut
st copains donc j'ai une étude dans mon
oeil quoi qu'est ce qu'il fait là ça
répond aujourd'hui meilleure émission à
l'hôtel sans rigoler à la bifurk et on
dirait une pub de france 3 qui vient
dans l'émission t elle dit que des trucs
ça nous rende anticyclone j'ai été faire
des buses et c'est là sa maman est
vraiment vous ne resterez une minute de
soleil en plus
ou est elle même et naïma ben tu manges
et des boulettes
alors vous madame oui kelly vdev dix
bonnes années
merci cette résolution l
il applaudit sur yahoo on dirait qu'ils
viennent de trouver un mot dans motus
flibustiers elle estimait m oui c'est a
tout eu tout
[Applaudissements]
allez on y va on touille déboule
attention pas la boule noire on y va
alors oui non j'ai pas spécialement de
résolution parce que je pense que tout
se passe bien gérer un a rectifié enfin
c'est bien au moins la sueur mais jamais
en question c'était et puis sinon je
pense que c'était important de pendant
ces vacances de renouer un petit peu
avec le passé voilà comme j'ai des
petits problèmes qu'on me propose des
autochtones des trucs comme ça j'ai fait
ce qu'il fallait faire pour prévoir tout
ça alors comprennent rien à perdre
elle sent la menace chassant la mène à
tout à l'heure
bon bah c'est bon elle est prête merci
pour ceux qui n'ont pas compris ce que
vient de dire qu'elle est bien entendu
qu on vous enverra un petit facile et
naturel prochaine vous le commencer nous
arrivera avec également une petite
maquette bien entendu c'est chez del
prado
merci à